game we got a low ticket Alert in
Cleveland and Columbus so if you want to
catch the show you better make a move
baby yeah gang there's a handful of
tickets left at each show and then
obviously the second show added at the
Vogel theater in Red Bank New Jersey
August 11th that's more than halfway
sold out get those tickets let's sell it
out gang we'll see you out there peace
peace welcome to another exciting
edition of are you garbage show where
you find out if your favorite comedians
are classy individuals or absolute trash
now here are your hosts Kevin Ryan and H
Foley
hey everybody out there and welcome back
to everybody's new favorite podcast this
is are you garbage hey it's that little
show we sit down with your favorite
comedians and we find out they're going
to be classy after just a big old piece
of trash I'm your host Dave trolley
coming at you on a beautiful day we're
out back here with titties and a new
edition she's down at the Supercuts
getting a little trim done pubes nah
take a little off the top get a little
cleanup done getting the beard trimmed
you know she does it play all beard
she likes to keep it tight getting the
stashed on sure everyone get lined up
you ever in the kitchen when she's
bleaching that thing Jesus Christ at the
neighborhood kids working for [__]
like The Lorax in there making eggs my
co-host is coming at you from across the
table this is a family episode he is the
CEO of Ru garbage he's got a hot cup of
coffee
I got nothing give it up for KJ Kevin
James Ryan thanks big man I appreciate
it shout out to everybody listening we
appreciate it uh if you haven't already
please make sure you rate if you
subscribe on iTunes even though that
don't mean nothing no more and you head
over to where it matters baby the
[__] where the money maker the uh
youtubes.com are you garbage as you know
those numbers are
cooking closing in on 150 000 Subs over
there love you that's [__] crazy
thank you and I'm not talking 150 000
submarine Sandwiches either big guy I'm
talking subscribers I always resent at
the submarine sandwich sure I'm sure you
have opinions on it sure also uh
obviously obviously patreon.com garbage
check it out you get bonus up two bonus
if you're on a 10 level you get two
bonus episodes every [__] week you
get a catalog of two and a half years of
[__] episodes every week you got
videos you got bonus videos the whole
nine yards Vlogs check it out gang you
like feet stuff huh check it out how
about tonight oops I went to the wrong
camera how about a nice question
all right welcome back the monitor's
throwing me off all right you're getting
all new equipment you're freaking me out
how about a nice quick shout out to our
producer X Jordan Air the magic man
makes us all look good works the ones
the twos crosses the t's that's the eyes
he's got a couple of tickets to a hot
rock show later tonight he's gonna be
out in the parking lot huffing balloons
give it up for T-Bone mcgruffins Toby
McMullen everybody what up dudes uh he's
a good kid don't do that what play was
it to do the helium voice hey guys sure
sure I'm just something too excited man
I'm going to see my favorite band and I
can't wait
man fire it up I'm being the pit out
there listening Eliza Minnelli
trying to crowd sir I was I was at
dinner and my mom goes my mom goes to my
dad she's like the Beach Boys Are Back
and I was like they're alive still The
Beach Boys Are Back we were just
listening to The Beach Boys today me and
new guy Luke he has a good ear for it
yeah but those guys are 90 years old
they're gonna wheel them out they're
gonna play two songs they're all gonna
die still got it and you know who they
got rolling with them Stamos
no shot he's the drummer what do you
mean Stamos is basically a beach boy
yeah you know when it all started off
Kokomo and let me tell you something
there wasn't a fat chick within a mile
to Mississippi that wasn't dying for
that song when it came out oh yeah oh
every month The Beach Boys went on Full
House Beach Boys went on Full House then
they dropped that gem put Stamos in the
video they sold millions of copies was
he what's he do for this singer or
drummer I think I might have just made
that up though I think you're buying
that off I think he does play the drums
Stamos plays the drums and various
percussion instruments on the Bongos
shout out to Stamos who Johnny pees boys
with man we're one step away from Stamos
man talk about a dream guest kid is a
looker [__] don't need blue for that
episode I'd be under here [__]
who's there boner town man really
carries himself well too he was just on
yani's pod or something they hang they
chill it's like him Yanni and some
whoever who's stamos's wife
yeah I know you don't know [__] look
it up
this guy gets the lights on I mean
freezes like a goddamn deer this is
Christ uh Caitlyn McHugh probably a real
heifer
probably a goddamn five piece he was
married to Rebecca Romaine Stamos none
of that was right Rebecca Romaine Stamos
for a long time I was always a kale
salad love Rebecca romance oh yeah she
was they were it they were like Mystique
right in the X-Men movies sure yeah yeah
all right got a little bit under boob on
that that's either here I also I just
invited you to a concert I got snubbed
and he said it with disgust I don't want
to go to the [__] Billy Joel concert
is it out store or indoor outdoor where
would it be playing outdoor the Joe man
I don't know the Yankee Stadium no it's
at MSG
um I know I don't want you to go I'm not
I'm not begging you to go I was trying
to do the nice friendly thing I had a I
had an extra ticket to the [__] you
don't want to take me I just asked yeah
yeah but that sad obligation what I had
two extra tickets who else is going you
both are for you
hahaha
you get seats two and three chubs
do you have two extra tickets no I have
one can I bring somebody Hey listen can
you not go and I'll bring my friends
muscle you out yeah get out of here
[__] disgrace the odd like I'm like
I'm not even his best pal I don't want
to go well I wasn't extended the invite
I'd go it's like I'm not a nerd [__]
that [__] yeah it's not Black Flag or
whatever you listen to yeah hell yeah
there ain't no pit at the Billy Joel
concert
hey those old bags get after it if you
need a root canal though don't
straighten you out over there
find another shorts Adonis over there
if you don't think that guy rocks the
house oh I bet he's a consummate showman
oh kills it still I mean one of the best
concerts I've ever been to was the joke
listen I am talking [__] but that talk
about a Hit Factory that guy we listened
to him we were in the car together we
listened to them all the time on the
road we're all singing along the scenes
from an Italian restaurant yeah we are
cold beer Hot Lights that's what I
wanted to name my house that's enough
I'm not getting sued by Billy Joel I
know
be right on the floor first section up
on them you kind of could play a young
old Billy Joel
okay it's not necessarily a capital
somebody is there a project in mind are
you doing a sitcom what do you want to
do a web series
um for that reason I'm out Only the Good
Die Young starting Kevin Ryan it's a
young or old no one knows how old I am
he looked old when he was young he looks
better now
I think he hit his straw I mean I'm not
now let's be honest he hit it he he hit
it in as he was older in like the 80s
and 90s yeah he looks great what do you
mean he looks fantastic yeah oh we
talking [__] Billy Jones Stamos cut all
this gonna get whacked out next time
we're at the Illuminati party
hey you go to those a lot
you got A plus one let's take me what
are we doing here see how the contract
goes first uh I'm excited to be my first
time ever at Madison Square Garden you
never saw a Nick game or nothing like
that why the [__] would I see a Nick
game fair enough 76ers I've never been
there once though yeah what do you mean
you've used it here for 38 years only
been there once probably to cop dope or
something
try to tried to sneak into [__]
you walk in here
gear is such a good name oh man it's so
here's all right makes it sound cool
when it's not kids don't don't be doing
gear
oh man lay off the gear meet me by the
loading docks straighten me out yeah
he comes out you're going I'm in a band
I don't know you need an opener or what
I got a question for you fellas I'm
listening ahead T-Bone what is it about
an old guy post 60 where the
gravitational pull of a recliner is
irresistible I brought Dr D and my mom's
check out the Edition here and within
I'd say about 35 seconds my dad was
sitting into his chair old guys like a
nice chair put your feet up man you guys
are working hard his whole life
Dirtbag kid like you chasing you around
bailing you out of jail putting you
through private school and all that [__]
uh Jesus Christ
yeah that's a lot
you're weird I'm sure he loves you just
dismantled my whole life in 30 seconds
yeah but whatever
because your dad likes to put his feet
up
yeah I don't know what it is there's
something about it something about it
really is I love it too and we still
have the robotic one uh that my dad had
um and then when I sit in that medicinal
medicinal robotic makes it sound cool
it's not from Sharper Image it's a
prescription recliner too I think it's a
Transformer
we got the robe so I'm over there
sitting on a robot's face it's a it's a
lazy boy but it like so are you
it lifts you up and everything
everything's automatic you don't got to
pull the the eject button you just you
have a little you have a little thing
sure I usually get that in the remote
confused all the time Jesus Christ he's
trying to turn the trying to turn the
volume upside down
[Laughter]
you know what we've got a lot of tweets
or whatever and so I I can't attribute
it to somebody but I don't know if we've
ever talked about it
um
couches let's couches with recliners in
them like the N2
I remember when we got my dad got them
first from Raymore and Flanagan green
like dark green couches pops out cloth
or leather cloth yeah I know leather
what are we Italian yeah uh that's what
Patty has now well leather's different
now back in the day to get leather you
got to be a guido sure uh a real guinea
[__] I had to have a white Christmas
tree
um
but the cup holders in how do you feel
about the cup holder in The Lazy Boy or
the couch
so to me I've lived in an apartment with
them in New York and
it's banned oh I know what you're
talking I know that you have a cup
holder I know the exact chair you're
talking there's always a lighter some
Shake in there yeah chewed up gum nah
that was that that setup was all right
that recliner that specific recliner
that recliner came from the track all
the furniture in that apartment came
from the side of the New York Street no
kidding yeah I wish I would have known
that
um sorry about the bed bugs but that was
all right because it had it was a double
cup holder so you had a little room and
that's what I remember was pretty clean
you put your drink there you put your
you know you had the remote and stuff
like that
my beef is well I have a problem with
those couches because my legs are so big
so now they have the buttons
in the cushion that leans up against the
armrest do you understand what I'm
saying
that's what that's what their little
side it's on the outside no it's not on
the over outside my mom has one where
this where it's the cushion and then the
ins like if you dropped a quarter inside
the couch oh they're in there it's on
the seat and my [__] fat legs rub
against it it's all sudden I'm [__]
sliding her in I think I'm going in the
MRI machine hear the motor going it's no
good it's hard smoking it's no good uh
but when they dropped I mean forget
about it but not the cup holder the cup
holder on the on the sectional
that's a bad look now if you have that
thing in the Middle where you flip it up
like it's the hood of a car keeps them
and you got some stuff in there that was
all right I don't know but those soft
cloth
sectionals that had where you had the
the the the manual pop it up that's what
we had oh yeah that thing's all right I
remember showing that off to friends
when they came over like yeah we got
that then come over and see it yeah
everybody would come over and say damn
that was fun come over and see the couch
just got a new that was one of the most
comfortable couches of my life was that
green couch at my dad's house that was
like [__] nuzzle out in there because
it went like flat back so as a kid you
could really get some horizontal sleep
in them dude we never had a sectional
until that's not a it wasn't a sectional
it was just a straight couch a
three-piece where the two ends went yeah
and then a two piece did it was it
together no oh a little coffee table in
there ashtray for your heaters sure the
guide yeah I'm a sectional man my
cousin's always had sectionals we didn't
have sectionals we had straight what's
the sexual connected right yeah
we never had that really I figured we
have it be all over that no we have one
and my mom has one now I think it's like
the it's all connected did yes it is but
those are the real nice ones that's a
nice couch when you get yourself in that
corner maybe you got a little feet but
the fancy thing about a school you're
snuggling up in the corner with the
comforter little Hogan's Heroes check
please the fancy thing about this one
it's not a hard L it's like a soft it's
got a soft turn in it that's like a
that's like a Las Vegas casino yeah yeah
I think you're about to watch a Sinatra
impersonator come out fly me to them
a couple more mozzarella sticks over
here table eight please hold that like a
cigar yeah yeah that's nice
um it's pretty close how about how do
you feel about the charge some of the
charger now too a charger they have like
a USB port now what is it a [__] the
car wash no you keep it simple
I'll give you the recliner all that
other stuff the recliner is that's no I
mean I'm sorry I'll give you the
recliner on the couch but all that other
stuff come on you get one of those as
seen on TV things that you throw over
like a saddlebag or you have a nice
[__] end table there turn the light
off watch a movie yeah yeah none of that
you don't want that rock and roll [__]
yeah they used to have the I don't know
but I think it came from my stepdad's
house it was the thing that went on the
the armrest like when he moved in you
know like the armrest and yeah you said
you put the thing over yeah saddlebag
saddlebags throw your magazines this was
a duck head and it was like yeah I know
exactly oh man I love that [__] yeah
Steve Irvin Steve Irwin playing with
that thing I remember the chairs that
would come with the little pocket on the
side it had like elastic on it that was
like a lazy boy type thing yeah oh those
are always blown out that was more like
a chair like that exactly not a lazy boy
but love the original recliner yeah
boys are big puffy Jones you're at your
grandma's house or a great aunt's house
you'd always find a couple of [__]
butterscotch root beer barrels in there
oh yeah dude those things are like
maternity pants dude why did those
ladies always have so much candy are
those fat little shits like us running
around yeah try to keep us at Bay it was
either that or make you lasagna
Hey kid go get a sugar high and pass out
shout out to my aunt Mary Catherine
always had the candy dish stocked like
the president was coming good [__]
though
um I wanted to ask you this ask me this
um I cleaned out my wallet the other day
got rid of some uh cards that had
expired and stuff like that moved some
things around
and I'm just reaching here I'm just
asking the question do you have they're
going to hit you do you have a Billy
Joel tickets yeah I got an extra who
needs two do you have you just sell them
there we go now if I say yes I'll go
with you and you sell them
what's my action coming my way on that
you know because you're just saying yes
to sell them I'm saying let's go back in
time and I didn't give you a whole bunch
of [__] about going to the concert I'm
gonna they were first of all they were a
birthday gift to me so I'm not going to
give you a part of my birthday gift
interesting yeah okay birthday gift I
got eight months late by the way if you
gave me one and I sold them I come in
I'm sitting next to [__] I'm getting
there
do you have an order of your CR of your
cards in your in your wallet like it
does it does the way they're stuffed in
together which I assume they're stuffed
in together
is there a system there or is it just a
free-for-all it's pretty much a
free-for-all that's the way I was uh up
until a couple of days ago it's tall
yeah I try to keep business and personal
on two sides
the first one up what do you think what
I mean yeah I've used the business
you're talking about that's the closer
first man through the door yeah he's
everything
uh step right over his body and finish
off this payment
get me groceries uh that only got you
about halfway put the rest on here uh no
I don't uh no it's chaos like I will try
to think of like all right this but like
I don't use the company debit card ever
anymore everything just goes on the on
the credit card sure so it's like things
that I don't use just fall to the back
the front two because I got like a
little side-by-side thing you know what
I mean it's just whatever yeah I also
have a weird thing where I have to look
at all the I have to pull them all out
to make sure they're all there before I
use one that's wild drives me crazy you
keep it you keep it whatever or you I
rock the phone case I got the phone case
with the slide out back and I'll tell
you what it was the debit was the lead
off and now I switched up to the AmEx
now they got that Platinum gotta get
them but here's the thing you keep
everything in the you lose the phone
you're [__] okay but you're double
[__] here's my defense my wallet doesn't
have a GPS on it I'm not chemically
addicted to my wallet like I am my cell
phone and he also doesn't drink you lose
your phone when you're drinking you
never like
oh I just randomly lost my phone the
only time I I you know you're always
like I got my you gotta have your phone
true so it's like that's the first thing
you go for if you go from here to over
there you go where's my phone yeah I I
haven't lost a phone since I quit
drinking
yeah there you go I don't know if I've
ever lost one I dude I lost I lost two
or three in a row within a couple of
months of each other one was stolen and
I lost the other two
I saw the guy walking away with this oh
yeah you told me yeah yeah I still don't
believe you about that
on West Third Street or whatever sold it
for drug buddy sold the Iggy Pop man I
lost my first smartphone it was like a
shitty Android lost it I had to go back
to the Nokia with the T9 Texan it was
brutal I wish we could go back to the
time where they were all burner phones
it didn't [__] matter what do you
mean burner phones when if you like when
it was the Motorola's or like the flip
phones if you lost one of those who
gives a [__] all you lost was your
contacts it wasn't your whole [__]
life in there plus somebody hacking into
it you get another one of those at the
mall in two seconds
you lost your contacts that's all it was
and your snake high score yeah
or 55. never forget you you remember the
important numbers back then anyway it
didn't matter now you lose it it's
[__] you're done it's over uh not
really no because that that information
is not stored in the phone it's stored
in your Apple ID which is somewhere else
you can just access on a new phone
that's true I just got it's not like
that would be insane if that was their
solution of like hey put your whole life
in here if you lose it you're [__]
well it's stored in a cloud I actually
it wasn't until maybe like a year or two
ago where I started with the cloud I
didn't trust the cloud for a while
there's a lot of stuff I don't trust I
didn't trust the cloud
I don't trust the talk to text I don't
trust this I got a new computer I
haven't put [__] tape on it yet
that's crazy how you doing buddy [__]
they're [__] peeping me
um [__] Putin just watching you yeah
uh yeah I don't trust talk to text I
don't do any of that [__] because I'll
be talking [__] on something the big
thing is if you're talking [__] on
someone I immediately my wife makes for
me because I'll grab my phone and look
at it to make sure I'm not calling them
and then put it down
probably [__] fully [__] fat piece
of [__] we're good yeah
what was I say yeah well now where was I
I was trashing someone so hard recently
that I put my phone on airplane yeah wow
I still heard the call damn I need to
know who that was was it part of the
organization first initials
outside editing it's a lie it's I made
it all up but we're vamping it's radio
that must have been some good attraction
right there
oh wait
run and put your phone upstairs
box get into the car you turn the radio
up holy [__]
just see it from the outside I'm like
what what all right let's quit screwing
around gang this is what we call the
Family episode out here at Cody's uh we
answer your questions on the air here uh
just for the homies and the bozos
[__] that up
okay the big man's on the fritz
all right gang let's quit screwing that
means I'm leaving all this in
pump fake you want me to do it no I
don't want it no I didn't or your
chair's about to break
I'll leave that in
that's why Hans was sniffing around back
there got a little got a little gas leak
going on
gang that's either here nor there it's
the [__] family episode we're gonna
be answering your questions right on
here cue ball take it away
that bothered me for some reason
all right this one guys when you sign up
for patreon we'll answer your garbage
questions Audi air you choose uh all
right there's one's from you did did you
fall you did I just saw you make icon
you farted oh dude
I apologize you can't be farting
mid-show man seriously you've done it
not like that
dude folks we'll be right back after
these important messages okay let's talk
about that liquid IV liquid eye vessel
let's talk about turning a bad night
around let me tell you something
it's not just for athletes it's for
drunks too yeah you're getting hammered
at night and trying to get your head on
straight before you go work a brunch so
you don't lose it on some customers some
kid looking for some chicken fingers
yeah I love liquid IV as everybody knows
I had got real sick a few weeks ago a
few months ago
nursed me back to health I was sucking
on that thing like Mother's Milk yeah
baby hydration it gives you everything
everything you need they got 12
delicious flavors like guava strawberry
try them all find your favorite baby I'm
the orange kind of the Citrus kind of
guy uzo pineapple all day proper
hydration is essential to your health
and liquid IV is the number one powdered
hydration brand in America it's taken
over I got family members that don't
even know but they don't even listen to
the show they're using it love it uh
real people real flavor real hydrating
grab your liquid IV and bulk nationwide
at Costco or you can get 20 off when you
go to liquid iv.com and use the code
garbage yeah that's 20 off anything when
you shop better hydration today using
promo code garbage at liquid iv.com do
it okay let's talk about manscaped
manscape manscape manscape let's talk
about Father's Day being right around
the corner and what better way to show
your dad you love them than by cleaning
up the front yard on them bald eagle all
day baby and the halfway backyard too
whatever he's into it I even I even use
it on My Face Gang do yourself a favor
go over there and pick up a a lawn mower
4.0 one of the best trimmers you could
possibly get keep the yard clean down
there keep the nuts fresh yeah baby they
got Cutting Edge ceramic blade a travel
lock and an LED spotlight so Dad can
shave his balls in the dark if that's
how he gets down we gotta cut that gotta
beat the bars on the energy bill too uh
your dad already has grooming Roots if
you're like mini golf with the glowing
balls if your dad already has his
grooming routine down hook them up with
the manscape boxers or some uh cologne
to get him smelling as great as he looks
baby here's the turkey get 20 off in
free shipping at manscape.com use the
code garbage that's 20 off and free
shipping at manscape.com promo code
garbage don't forget that you came from
your dad's balls this and this year's
show your original home some love with
some man's cake
that's good copy
screwing around
her ass cleared the room uh all right
this one's from Ice Sox chairman and CEO
uh 10 Bozo over here never had one red
how many lanes of traffic can you cross
on foot before it's trash saw a lady
crossing a busy five Lane Road no
crosswalk just Frogger in it out
man seeing somebody walking on the
highway that's [__] we'll give you a
chill we've talked about this a lot it's
crazy it's St but like I've been in
those situations where you you don't
have a car you got to get the a pack of
it's never you're never going to talk to
your wealth manager listen you're going
to get a pack of heaters get some gear
or get to work listen 80s 90s early
2000s that was a different time sure you
can't be doing that now
that that's crazy I mean people do it
people have to do it all right it sucks
I would say three lanes each way that no
and no divider if you have one of those
dividers you're screwed that's too much
three and three each way three each way
no you're saying I think that's too much
you think so six Lanes of traffic
no
you gotta walk to a crosswalk at that
point or at least a light if it's like a
bypass if you're just raw dogging it
between exits no way gotta jump over the
wall at the end figure a skin walker
get out of here dude no uh I would say
it depends if it's like a highway
highway what is a Highway exactly
because they they're expanding roads all
the time well I do think there's like
what I would call like a bypass or a
Boulevard which is like two to three
lanes Queens Boulevard let's use that I
don't know that no it's a real loose
terminology a highway is a main road
especially one connecting major towns or
cities all right how about an interstate
it goes state to state that's crazy if
if you're on if you're Crossing
something that has the blue and the red
logo
that's bad news yeah you can't be on 95.
you're J yeah you're jammed up yeah
you're a real Road you shouldn't be
Crossing oh [__] there's a toll involved
well no I'm not saying you're [__]
waiting in the easy pass line just
saying you shouldn't be jumping anything
with a toll
you gotta be doing it by all I've just
done I've done it though man it sure
sucks it's [__] as you're doing it
you're like this this is not good you're
like really analyzing how you got to I
always had to do it when I was doing
[__] places on the road without a car
when we're in Lancaster Lancaster I was
doing a
whatever the club is out there where's
the sheets a couple right across the way
there you think it's in the parking lot
it's [__] on the other side of a nine
Lane Highway dude on the side of the
turnpike it was like I didn't cross the
turnpike but I was [__] I was hopping
some medians to get to a [__] you
know whatever go get a Sammy late night
oh man it's a good question yeah that's
a tough look don't be doing that yeah
finally getting Uber or something I mean
I guess I guess Uber probably took a lot
of that out if that's an option
the Uber's not an option does that make
sense if crossing the highways on the
table the Uber's off the table does that
make sense I see what you're saying but
sure I see what you're saying of course
but yeah that ain't great you shouldn't
be doing that
um this one's from Greg ten dollar homie
is it garbage to mix Bud Light and
Budweiser to make Bud medium
that's pretty [__] good dude have you
talked to anybody about this but mediums
bug me I could pull them out of the fire
that's pretty good that's real good a
bud do you looking up that what was Bud
Select that might have been in there
that might have been in the medium oh
that was watching Devil Wears Prada the
other day and that's what they were
drinking was Bud hey dude Bud Select
really went on an all-out assault on
pushing that stuff sucked it was like
the black it was like a darker bottle
crown on it yeah I don't know I don't
know who they were fighting who they
were trying to compete with with that I
was probably trying to get that middle
ground of like butt head butt heavy is
made of more of a resurgent as of
recently of the past like decade
beeradvocate.com rates Bud Select 51
awful yeah but I'll tell you what what's
Bud wiser
a bud heavy cold bottle we had a couple
this weekend oh I've been drinking
[__] delicious it's all I've been
drinking man
something about that class gets it is
this weekend we were with the boys oh
that's right yeah 57 also awful these
guys
[__] out of here with that [__]
[__] what murder
he's a great guy
laughs
thank you to the 10 000 people who've
tagged me in that clip what mark
ers
this boy's the best he's always set up
they just said that oh God that's
[__] all right uh let's see here on
mediums Bud mediums I don't hate it
cause I do love Bud Heavies and I do
love BLS something in the middle
that's all right it's all right watch
the calories a little bit sure you know
keep your wits about you for an extra 20
minutes or whatever bud mediums that's
all right mediums there you go someone
no one's done that yet I just gotta feel
like that's got to be something they've
never done that with that marketing I'm
just saying I'm sure like people haven't
done that you know
out there someone hasn't figured that
out like on the golf course or [__]
something sure you know hey we do Bud
mediums over here half and half at a bar
or something
pictures of Bud mediums half off or
something dude there's nothing better
than a pitcher of beer think so oh cold
bottle cold can yeah but I never had a
good picture let me say it let me see
really never whoa never
it was always plastic or it sucked or
the the plastic doesn't matter the Taps
were gross never had a good picture of
beer huh swear to God
never had a great tag either except for
one time you're nuts I'm telling you
grow up under a rock this [__] guy
telling you me and my boys never knew
really how to get to to do the pump
right to do The Keg right never got it
right
yeah I don't know I was I was pretty
handy with a tap used to have a tap back
in the day obviously you got a house in
college out of attack sure
um but a pitcher I think we like the
pictures so much
cause you're a dirt ball we were dirt
balls one it was a better bang for your
buck
it was about eight beer or I thought was
it four beers in there I think like four
point something beer four beers
uh and
it was the speed you could consume
I'll give you that right it was like if
I get an IPA in a bottle I pour it into
a glass so I can yeah get it down the
gullet I was somewhere I was in Philly
two weeks ago or whatever that was
[__] we went out to dinner I ordered
a beer next guy next to me ordered a
beer was a main lunch which is like the
best I they said the best IPA you can
get I think I'll do one everybody got
one she goes you want a picture I said
do we ever doing pictures of ipas and
thinner maybe that's why I threw up that
night
maybe it wasn't the food poisoning like
I thought it was in the calamari
um
uh on which oh I don't know you were
looking like you had something I have a
few things actually I hit him I got a
couple things lined up all right have
you heard of any of these Budweiser
makes a ton of beers that I've never
heard of lay them on me Budweiser
Supreme that's got to be European black
and gold can Budweiser Supreme yeah
sounds like a Chili's dish yeah
only available Mexican restaurants uh
Budweiser Select 55 premium light I do
remember a 55 because that's I think the
engine MGD came out with 64 and they
were a number and it was a number it was
a [__] yeah it was like a nuclear
race before they're not really around
anymore Miller Genuine Draft I don't
think all right but this one sounds like
something you get at Starbucks Budweiser
Nitro Reserve gold wow
that'll put you to sleep I don't know
what it is yeah damn this is a specialty
golden lager brewed with 100 American
barley included toasted caramel malt for
a bold flavorful taste nah never had any
of that [__] no
no that's uh my dad dabbled in red dog
for a little bit we didn't even do that
we were Killian's Irish Red I remember
we had that at christening one time
everybody got [__] crippled yeah it
looks like you're [__] once
did it just come out my cousin duck
cracked open I can't get that man we
were [__] seeing cross-eyed that and
smittix or whatever that was real
[__] potato [__] that was real
[__] Kali t-shirt if you ask me
get me a smittix uh now stick with a
Michelob please
I gotta drive in a week
I got a test coming up next month that's
I'm taking the SATs at the end of the
month submitting smittix was that [__]
was
yeah the 90s 90s in the 2000s they got
real crazy with the beer yeah The
Branding of like let's cut it in half
and we'll do this we'll throw a number
on it yeah a little lemon
yeah that was none of them ever [__]
stuck though no you ever go somewhere
where someone's drinking shark top
Shock Top Shock Top shark top land shark
and Shock Top yeah that's like a bud
medium it's half and half in both cases
I know the place is gonna suck Lane
sharks land sharks and yeah shout out to
the land cheetle they are fantastic
at a restaurant anywhere dude when those
hit first of all you know who makes them
Budweiser Jimmy Buff Jimmy Buffett
that's right that guy knows the way
around a pop all right pretty good Jimmy
Buffett damn it he's got that too
give me the net worth on Jimmy B
outrageous I'm sure let's take a guess
everybody put up everybody put up 100
million dollars whoever's closing 500
million dollars
half a bill no way 350. that's what I'm
saying 500.
no wonder why your dad doesn't like you
give me one of them sharks I'll do 440.
billionaires yeah man wow plus you got
to think [__] his cousin's probably
gonna leave him a couple of bucks
he's not his cousin yeah he is Warren
Buffett is Jimmy Buffett's cousin that's
um the [__] out of here they're not
cousins that's where he got the seed
money I'm telling you all that margarita
man please let me be right there's no
way that's how Dirtbag I am I thought
they were gone somebody told me they
were cousins like a decade ago shout out
to Pete oh no but they did they're not
but they did take a 23andMe DNA test to
see if they were wow which is fun wow
they're not yeah they're still buds
though you
probably running your mouth at Christmas
parties all [__] up on land shorts
yeah I was [__] that just dude hey
there's any Crockett's cousin
did you ever hear someone tells you
something you just believe it man that
rattled me it's a Mandela effect that's
not lies lies there's something wrong
something wrong yeah I had bad
information that's not the Mandela
effect all right Butterfly Effect
still not that
Auto-Tune
After Effects Reverb uh put a filter on
it what murders
I'm gonna be saying that forever man
Pete that dude Pete that I used to work
construction was lied to me oh Pete the
construction worker to know what the
[__] he was talking about he was a good
guy
plumber what plumber
stolen copper what's stolen copper he's
a good guy damn I've been telling people
that for years oh man I can't lose the
first time I got tripped up all night I
have a couple of those but I told people
for a long time I told people for a long
time that the guy who played the
professor on Gilligan's Island was the
Zodiac Killer well that was a thing
right that could have proved it pretty
quick yeah I mean you stopped me from
running like yeah you know who really
did it
it was the skipper
uh yeah that was there was that kind of
uh he like had been in the towns or
something or yeah shooting movie and
like lined up with his movie shooting
yeah schedule or whatever something
um
what murder uh all right Warren Buffett
Jimmy Buffett her cousin that's
devastating dude that's where you know
it's Shifty brothers sisters is one
thing when somebody says they're cousins
what do you mean
could have been a very big family
with two billionaires what family has
two billionaires probably most families
that have billionaires yeah but that's
different they started out as
billionaires
there wasn't two families that were both
poor that became billionaires
the Winkle bosses they came they became
billionaires together and I doubt that
they're billionaires no they were the
first Bitcoin billionaires they took all
that Facebook money and put it in
Bitcoin during the first surge did they
I believe I don't know what to believe
out of here
[__] guy
if I can get a read on that I believe
they were the first crypto billionaires
lunch this too oh man swinging a Miss
for Kippy over here ah Kippy nailed it
yeah first Bitcoin billionaires uh-huh
there you go put that in your little
pipe and bite down will you jump
[__] take my back my invitation to
the Billy Joel concert
okay let's talk about pretty litter
you ever walk into somebody's place and
they got cats and you're like oh I gotta
eat this I used to do it at your place
not no more because we got pretty litter
I know the kitty cat loves it I gotta be
honest with you it's absolutely
fantastic pretty litters crystals even
change color
to indicate
any early signs of potential illness in
the cat how about that technology I know
apparently I have feline diabetes how
about that ad read too the kid really
nailed that gang you want to take care
of your pets you want to take care of
your kitty cat get yourself some pretty
litter and straighten him out yeah again
uh pretty little even chips for free
right to your door so you'll never
you'll never have to run out and you'll
have to Lug one of those huge plastic
containers from the grocery store like a
bozo yeah uh pretty litter has helped
eliminate cat box stink in uh in the big
man's house specifically it can do the
same for you make the switch today go to
prettylitter.com garbage and use code
garbage to save 20 on your first order
that's pretty litter.com garbage code
garbage to save 20 off your first order
one more time pretty little.com slash
garbage code garbage terms and
conditions apply seed to site for
details do it I'm back to the shower
back to the show
uh all right let's see here
um this is from Jared new sub never had
one red at any point did you do you or
do you currently have a cupboard filled
with assorted license plastic cups
licensed plastic cups like a Disney uh
uh you know uh character types or movie
type stuff I mean we talked about our
favorite cups as kids and all that stuff
those have kind of been
faded out in at my mom's sure the
dishwasher changes those after
chemically changes those afterwards but
for a while it really ripens them like
fine wine yeah but then they can't
perfect the Cascade taste lingers on
them a little I understand I know but I
understand that but I'm saying it then
gets to a point where you're it's not
Sprite in there it's you know it's a
good Escape you know it's a good
combination all right this is real
specific and this is real Nuance okay
[Music]
a weathered cup like that a little bit
faded you can smell the dishwashing soap
in the bottom of it then you add the ice
from the door of the freezer that kinda
had that distinct smell yeah the half
moon shape yeah yeah put a little Pepsi
on that you get down to the bottom of
that and you put your nose in it and the
cold of the ice and the smell of the
Cascade and the little bit of essence of
the of the door of the refrigerator
man you're a different kind of fat yeah
that was really good that was just wrote
a novel on [__] drinking dishwashing
[Laughter]
it was you know what our bed is a snack
SOS pad it was better when it when it
wasn't dishwasher it was just it was
just handished I never lived in a life
with that when we were when I we never
had an ant that didn't have a dishwasher
I'm sure but not that I could
pull if I you know not like that no I'm
sure we did but we always had a
dishwasher it was real hot for a while
you remember the cups that had like the
it was almost like paneling that went
around it yes
those things we had them grip we had
them at my dad's they were they were
little chodes a little short ones yeah
we couldn't use them why the kids
couldn't they were plastic no oh you're
talking about plants plastic one I know
the glass ones you're talking about pint
glasses that had sides yeah I mean yeah
that's that's I mean that might as well
been [__] Waterford Crystal sure sure
uh oh the little plastic bag they were
like Ikeas or something yeah yeah man I
always felt like they should be holding
candles sure you know what I mean I
didn't I didn't like drinking out of
them plus they rough jump on the [__]
inside of your sometimes sometimes you
you cut a little little action and you
would they would get dropped enough that
they would like shatter but stay like
they would like you could see the
plastic splinter in it oh okay so that's
a that's a that's the same model
different kind of plastic I like that
kind of plastic that's summer plastic to
me the kind of clear stuff that's a
little bit harder it's not that flexible
I don't like that oh I loved it no it's
either called a summer plastic I don't
know why because you're crazy it feel it
felt like that those were things that
got broken out in the summer you know
it's great that you'll still get
sometimes at some diners uh is like the
yellow
sometimes you'll get the glass one yeah
uh not the Pizza Hut ones yellow yellow
glass yeah that's weird like gold you
know what I'm talking about
what am I a jerk of I wouldn't trust
that I don't think what do you mean
yellow Diner cup glass with the yes I do
it's similar Bill to the red ones yeah
that's what I just said that's similar
to the red ones that ain't glass yeah I
said plastic but they do come in glass I
said not the red ones that's what I said
they're similar okay yeah yeah
um yeah those are all right yeah now
Patty doesn't have anything like that
which she does have now
is some things that she bought for like
a party that would be like summery
drinks does that make sure
yeah there's a lot of them floating
around uh-huh and a couple Notre Dame
glasses that are thin man they hold a
Diet Coke like the Hoover Dam uh oh yeah
we don't have anything a lot of shitty
to-go cup coffee cups at my mom's
currently at the niece's house then down
the shore we got a lot of Stella glasses
that I we're either probably have stolen
or bought they came with like a gift
six-pack type thing hey Stone
maybe I got three mugs and a stack of
Solo cups Jesus Christ you're drinking
Solo cups all day okay goddamn frat
party what do you have in the fridge
what drink wise nothing big old Brita
filter that's what you're drinking
you're drinking water out of a Solo Cup
oh yeah no ice nah yikes
how's the manifesto going yeah that's
crazy when was the last time you changed
that filter well when I bought it when I
bought it I made a big to-do with you
about how I was gonna be on top of it I
was gonna change it you said in one year
I bet you won't have changed it and I'm
here to tell you I think about that all
the time while I'm not changing
can I tell you this there you go give me
my money we put money on it that's
probably that [__] dripping slow
dude can I tell you you don't really
need it it's just that it's cold
yeah the fridge cleans it out anyway it
just tastes fresh clean water every time
I fill it up mentally it does
you feel like you're drinking cleaner
water if it's cold in a pitcher oh yeah
yeah just get rid of that thing plus
it's a pain in the ass we have the one
that uh it goes in there and you have to
that's what I gotta turn it yeah but
that does it as it's going out
does that make sense the filter is is
where the spigot is dude it's it's like
I'm watching a [__] toddler take a
leak it's [__] brutal telling you we
got the [__] doctor's office John
yeah it's great fresh clean water all
day every day
what Waters
you think I'm not screaming at you that
screaming at you for the next three
weeks
this is from disappointing salad is it
garbage in a microwave your your pizza
Lunchables
I live I'm on record I've never been a
big lunchable guy I think if you're
gonna go through the if
I don't know
because if you're going to go through
all this work why not just do something
a little better than the pizza
Lunchables unless that's how you get
your rocks off or put it in a toaster
oven like a gentleman something like
you're doing the extra step
you can you know why stop there then
type thing that's what I'm saying let me
ask you this ask me if you got uh
windshield wipers would you put them on
the other way or would you do is the
[__] manufacturer recommends doesn't
recommend that you microwave it no they
recommend they eat them cold and stop
being a [__] [__] you don't put that
[__] in the microwave you eat it cold in
the goddamn lunchroom I thought he was
mad at me uh a little bit yeah I don't
know why what microwave
what lunchable
um
also the red text is what murders
uh I do get I do I do understand
churching it up a little bit but
I don't know that's bad yeah I would say
no I would say yes it's trashy I would
say I would say you don't need it I
would say just have it cold like a
gentleman that's that's that's that's
just me you do whatever you want
obviously I [__] love you enjoy
yourself but come on
yeah it's tough uh all right this one's
from Riley have you ever refilled the
Gatorade nipple tip bottles after you
drank all the Gatorade
I guess with water like you're using it
as like a workout bottle vehicle
which I never liked those to begin with
there's not enough in there Kippy let me
tell you something we've never
we're right here the [__] dishwasher
detergent top
on on drinks
get the [__] out of here with that [__]
what I feel like I'm drinking Palmolive
the nipple Oh I thought you went back to
the dishwasher soda cup no no no at
first time I thought we were I thought
this was fighting no this is you and me
right there I can't get a read on you
today big fella somebody get them is
meds me and you okay yeah so there's not
enough
it's that you never finish it and it's
also like the like the yeah I feel like
I'm [__] a big fat baby and here's
the problem the bottle size is a little
bit bigger
it's perfect it's like Goldilocks it's
perfect but you I just take it off and
drink out of it like a [__] [__]
just get rid of that [__] man wait is it
bigger than the 20 ounce it's a little
bit bigger they're the perfect size
the Estancia sport or the SmartWater
sport are the perfect size but they put
those [__] stupid things on there
nobody wants to talk about your Gatorade
or all of them everything I was just
using them as a reference gotcha yeah no
the the size thing a Gatorade one oh you
know wait you're not talking about a
Gatorade green bottle that they give you
on when they come over on the sidelines
they have
they were like the first ones to put the
nipple slip on yeah those things suck
they stink it should they've I think
they're the same size as the 20s they're
just skinnier and taller they might be
24. yeah maybe it's a psychological
thing but no the water companies are
different the water companies are
totally the water brands are totally
different and the the one with the
nipple top is the best it's not the 16
ouncer and it's not the 32 ounces yeah
it's not the [__] big the thing that
doesn't fit in the in the cup holder in
the in the car then you got it on the
seat then you hit the brakes and it
falls over then the kids are crying now
she's leaving you all right nipple top
Gatorade uh coming in at 24 ounces so
the other ones are probably 20 right
like a standard Gatorade standard
standard gate we'll get you 20 ounces
and then you got the big boys oh you go
big boy wait hold on we're talking is
the big boy the little fat one
yes oh that's that's 32 right that's it
Wawa also used to run deals like two for
four so two for five gave them away dude
you'd be dude I would be doing [__]
1400 calories in the car just [__]
taking my [__] my daily minimum in
let me tell you something in liquid a
screaming cold Gatorade is a tough tough
tough to beat yeah no for sure that's
[__] that's all right let me tell you
let me tell you there uh all right let's
see here this is from Mikey Whispers
yeah do you or anyone in your family
have license plates hung inside your
home we have one here we do because that
is a trash thing yeah I don't think we
ever had one I wanted one couple in the
garage people had them in the garage hit
a few in the garage yeah I always wanted
one I never and Uncle collected them or
something like that never had one yeah
uh I remember I remember we had to do a
a report on like a state in like [__]
fourth grade or whatever and I did
Nebraska because my uncle lived there I
don't know I just like [__] picked
Nebraska and I was like yeah I was like
oh yeah just like send me a license
plate you had to like bring in stuff or
something and he's like I'm like yeah
you know just send me some like Nebraska
stuff and he's like what do you want I
was like I was like I don't know man
like whatever you got he's like what do
you want to go Studio license plate or
something I'm like no that'd be crazy
but that's what I totally wanted I
always wanted a license plate they're
cool man a vanity plate something get
one on the Kia
also that reminds me I gotta change my
[__] because I got new tags
you never changed them that was like no
oh I changed them that was that was a
long time I changed them I didn't change
my insurance
Jesus that got me and also I never
changed my registration they've been
jamming me up every time I get tickets
[__] that just reminded me
I gotta get my car inspected
[__] are you inspected in New York or
Pennsylvania New York okay yeah [__]
gentleman yeah it's expensive what does
that mean no it was like 13. it's
literally 13 it took the guy four
minutes oh yeah I remember you tell him
yeah it was I think it was 13.50 that's
that's what my mom was saying yeah gotta
get it registered up there the insurance
I'll be through the roof
I don't [__] know either way I'm a
[__] idiot hey no you're not
you're a good guy he's an idiot what it
is all right let's see this no it's not
uh
this one's from Thai ten dollars Soldier
long time first time I strip my own
hotel sheets and put them in a pile with
the towels embarrassed of any and all
stains I never tip but feel like I'm
doing a lot of the work trash or class
um
I gotta say
that's your meeting in the middle I get
it but if they're that dirty you should
be dropping two three bucks if they're
that stained someone's got to pick up
your poop stains you got a tip you gotta
tip
if it wasn't for the reason I don't know
what he's doing in there but I don't
think it's good if it was just if it was
just looking out that's got to be the
biggest pain in the ass in the room is
[__] dealing with that [__] if you're
just looking out but there's but yeah
what am I talking about yeah not the
sheets the towels you're supposed to put
in a pile and leave a couple of bucks
you got a tip you're right yeah you
gotta you put you organize everything
yeah you don't live like animal I use
every towel
oh yeah every town oh you know what I
did I was just I stated when I stayed in
Philly I had [__] hanzi Ponzi Shama
Lama danzi and I was letting them sleep
in bed with me but we'd walk in the city
and Philly and his paws would get all
dirty so I would use the towels to clean
his paw and they were like [__] black
by the end dude I ran through every hand
towel every face tell the thing that you
for the shower everything yeah sorry no
Yeah just they bleach it [__] cook it on
high send them out I think they don't do
them there
uh probably got a service yeah maybe I
don't know yeah
um all right let's see let's do two or
three more uh
um Sofa King garbage long time homie
never have one red as a garbage for Mom
still keep some of your a lock of your
hair that was a rat tail damn yikes
yikes well you weren't allowed to have a
rat tail were you how long will you let
did you get
for a rat tail yeah that was how trashy
you were
because it's how long the parents would
let the tail go yeah not not a not a
mullet and not a rat tail but a tail a
rat tail they were called rat tails I
had one no a rat tail was braided up no
it could just be a long in the
background
the whole way just down like the nape of
the neck oh God yeah that's right I had
short and then I had the uh so you had a
rat tail big time you gotta even look
like a teenage Jedi
what age are we talking uh Elementary
School North Carolina man yeah I'll give
you that to South
that is real Southern [__] oh yeah like
like and like you would get me even if
you came in if you were just I
Associated that with your dad ain't
around and your mom works a lot no that
was your trailer park or Southern to us
when we were when we were big kids were
doing that though you were a skate kid
no that was Dirtbag that's Dirtbag no
that's before skate that ain't skate hmm
that's like seven six seven eight years
old rocking a rat tail
and we would you would even if you came
in just wolfing it I remember one time I
was wolfing a little bit that kid for
sure had Kool-Aid around yeah yeah and
cut off jean short song
pair of Daisy Dukes
but I remember the people were calling
me rat tail one time because I was just
wolfing in the back I went home was like
yo let's hit the barber [__] they're
calling me a hillbilly it's cool
[__] out of here I gotta ride the super
cancer
getting it cleaned up yeah uh uh I think
there was a time when we did some lines
here in the early 90s we had like one or
two lines Here For Speed yeah clearly I
put lines on my hair and I had a number
one famously I've said I had my boy
Ernie put lines in my hair
Holy Saturday the Night Before Easter
and you would have thought that I had
burned down the [__] Church yeah my
mother you Heathen my Easter Sunday
You're Gonna Go like that they were
always big on linking it to whatever
they were it's Christmas it's funny
[__] what you're like just shut up
I'm an idiot
do you think I'm thinking I'm just
looking at my hair
you guys were the age where you were
putting them in your eyebrows right the
lines in your eyebrows now who was doing
that not me no uh-uh
somebody was recently recently I don't
know I think the kids are doing it now I
think
I would have figured if you're 10 years
older than me they do a lot of mullets
now to kids the mullets are big yeah
yeah because it became ironic like hey
that guy is so you know doesn't care
he's got a mullet you know what I
thought was a little Pinnacle it really
was it obviously it it got overblown but
the European soccer cut which I kicked
for a little while about 15 years ago
which was what the high in tight what
the back was a little bit long you know
what I'm talking about like you had it
when we before we first met yeah and I
thought you were the I still not even
Joe I don't know if I ever share this
with you I've never seen your haircut in
a YouTube video and I was like this guy
stinks dude I swear to God
you were like singing into your webcam
or something at that apartment you used
to live in no no that was different that
was that was it was the enema video
that was a mullet I'm talking that
wasn't a mullet I'm talking the European
I thought it was a mullet I'm talking
European soccer cup where where it would
like go it would go in but it was longer
I had it when you knew me for sure
I had it in New York for a little while
I don't know do you not know what I'm
talking about no are you [__] nuts
give me a guy who had it I don't know
put hot soccer player haircut that'll
just gonna get hot guys now yeah what
haircuts it's all kind of like faux
hockey yeah that's what I'm talking
about a faux hawk thank you oh the faux
hawk I think that's the [__] coolest
haircut around
man I've had bad haircut you have also
had a handful of bad haircuts
um I rock the faux hawk not a fauxhall
well faux hawk is like
really all right
I went I had like almost got that
what God what bad joke yeah no I had a
mohawk just not bit I had a one on the
side
but how wide was it what the Mohawk yeah
it was about 200 feet
it was big enough you can cross it in
the middle of the night about a Tree
Lane Highway
I gotta wrap it up you gotta take an
Uber gotta cross that thing and he's
done as a Barking Lot
used to play football there on Sundays
uh you're not gonna beat the first one
get out but I'm still trying
gang
it's a turkey we love you to death
uh-huh and we'll see you next week